Rita, Justin, congratulations.
You guys have made
it to the final round
of this competition.
Now it's time to send you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
And that weapon is--
the sodegarami.
Holy.
Jeez.
Oh my god.
MAN: Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
I've never made a
sodegarami in my life.
First time I've ever heard of
it was when they unveiled it.
It's going to be a learning
experience for everybody.
I'm going to make Damascus.
My goal today is just to
get a few billets welded up.
So we're going to
do a 15 and 20.
We'll clean that first, and
then we'll move on to our 1084
and clean that up.
I'm not going to
go crazy with it.
I don't want to do
anything super elaborate.
The next process
is going to be just
welding these bad boys together
and getting a billet together.
Day one in the books.
Things went pretty well.
We got a couple of
billets welded up.
Tomorrow we'll be
making spikes and doing
all kinds of fun stuff.
Day three, yesterday, I was
able to finish up my spikes.
I got all of my tines started.
Today I am going to
start with my entangler.
Super awesome.
For this sodegarami,
I'm going to have
the theme of the octopus.
The octopus is an animal
that entangles its prey,
and I think that's a fitting
theme for this weapon.
So I want my entangler to
emote octopus tentacles.
Ah.
It's time for me to quench.
Woo-hoo.
My quench went well.
The head of the sodegarami
looks pretty good.
At the end of day three,
everything is built,
and I can start putting
this together tomorrow.
Day three, we're going to
try to do some heat treat,
make sure this thing's ready
to put together and test.
I cut the billet
into four pieces.
I'm going to forge these
out into the four spikes
in the front of the sodegarami.
Hoping I'm going
to start shaping
these and pulling
little leaves off them
to do some backwards barbs.
Coming together.
For the handle, I'm using
a curly ambrosia maple.
Feels pretty solid.
Feel like a Ninja Turtle.
It's time to quench.
Go ahead and harden
just the blade.
Leave the rest soft so
that when they smack it
into whatever they're going
to smack it in, hopefully
it won't break.
Just quenched five blades.
My back hurts.
My legs hurt, but
you got one more day.
Got to knock it out.
Halfway through
the last day, I
plan to have this
sodegarami built.
I'm feeling pretty good
after getting to spend
this time on the weapon.
I'm excited to see
that I could do it,
and I'm excited for my daughter
and my scouts to see, too.
[non-english speech]
Done pretty much
everything I wanted to do,
but I have time to
do one more thing.
Stab.
So I test my sodegarami
one more time.
Yoink.
And I hear a little noise.
Ah!
Oh, [bleep].
I got to fix this.
Son of a [bleep].
I spent a lot of
time on this weapon,
and I've broken this thing.
So I'm just going to run back
and put whatever kind of crappy
weld I can get on it.
If this doesn't
work, I'm screwed.
Day four, ready to get
this thing assembled.
Got about 1,000
different processes
to get through today--
sharpening spikes,
welding spikes,
blade sharpening and shaping.
Got about 1,000 tasks.
A little Mongolian horse hair.
That is a blood guard.
[bleep]
Putting the head in, and it
seems like it wanted to split
on me, so we're going to throw a
little bit of epoxy and leather
around this thing and
call it what it is.
If something goes
wrong with my weapon,
it's going to be that I
wasn't able to pin the head.
Just didn't have
the time to do it.
Hopefully it stays together.
Sodegarami build is done.
She might not be pretty,
but she will KEAL.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the KEAL test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your sodegarami will do,
I will take your
weapons and stab
and try to snag this
ballistics dummy.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Aye.
[laughs]
All right, Rita.
Let's talk about
your sodegarami.
The tines you have
here penetrates.
The hook you have here
will rip this person apart,
and, more importantly,
your weapon will KEAL.
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You ready to have fun?
Yes, sir.
All right, Justin.
The tines you have here,
it's more of a stabbing tine
rather than a grabbing.
And this is a
grabbing weapon, but
that hook does grab on to that.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will KEAL.
All right, bladesmiths.
It's time for the strength test,
the dreaded ice block chop.
Remember, this is not
about what these weapons
do to the ice blocks.
It's about what those ice
blocks do to your weapons.
And, Rita, you're up first.
You get points for theme.
I mean-- [laughs]
You ready?
It doesn't matter, right?
No, it doesn't matter.
[grunting]
All, right, Rita.
You a little bit more of a
bend in this one tine here.
But everything else is pretty
much the way it was going in.
Definitely held up.
Did its job.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
All right, so you
survived the strength test.
This is a very strong,
well-built head for this,
but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching.
I mean, I'm not
sure how effective
it would be at
snagging the opponent,
but it's a devastator.
It certainly did the job.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the sharpness test,
the sandman pierce and capture.
To test the sharpness,
I will take your weapon,
pierce, and try to
control this sandman.
Rita, you're first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
All right, Rita.
The points you have
on your tines here
definitely penetrate when
you thrust into that,
but doesn't slice on
the way out or capture
as well as it should.
Your hook over here did its job.
Overall, it will
cut and control.
All right, Justin.
Your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
That's not good.
(WHISPERING) He pulled
it out of the socket.
Well, Justin,
we have a problem.
Yes, sir.
This wasn't pinned, was it?
No.
The impact from all
these tests loosened it up,
and, of course, it came off.
Justin, you brought in a
beautifully-crafted weapon.
However, you've suffered
a catastrophic failure
in our final test.
And, unfortunately,
you cannot be
our "Forged in Fire" champion.
Congratulations, Rita.
Thank you.
It was beautiful.
Coming on "Forged in Fire,"
I proved what I wanted to do,
that people with
physical limitations
can do as well as anybody.
I put my all into it, and I
feel like I made a good weapon.
But just came up
short on a little bit
of the fit and finish, and other
than that, I'm happy with it.
Rita, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
How do you feel right now?
I'm just--
Come on forward
and shake our hands.
Good job.
It's been a very
positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do
something amazing like this.
I hope this will help me
become an inspiration to kids
because I can say, look,
if you see something
and you want to try
it, give it a try.
Hey, Weeblos, your scout
leader is the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I'm bringing it home.
Can I have a group hug, please?
[laughter]
Thank you, you guys.
Oh my god.